hello and welcome and tues video playing
drama Santino I don't think he's an end
I was anonymous guy right here I have no
particular oops memory about playing him
ah i cannot remember anything is he now
threatening to take it i don't think he
is aren't you form oh my god that's a
problem if you hit play such a line and
you have no complete idea but should be
six or something ah now i mean in the
quesadilla you know some things about
his opening prolly
I kind of fear but at some point he will
take it should be six looks normal but
maybe the five and it is going to be
possible now
okay i'm gambling on that
so it seems that he can take now but it
said really that is a year i mean if i
take age two and take on here and why
was this going to play out oh no ok is
it possible that all this is like theory
and i have just no clue it's very
possible but it sent three a five or
what is he doing fatigue d4 he plays me
five but i have 95 actually why doesn't
that work 95 i'm indy room shakes I'm
probably just losing on time here I'm
down three minutes oh yeah that happens
there you play you play a main line and
don't know it and they just dash out I
have to move after move after you and
you don't even know if it's a nonsense
always add roof if that is really the
main line
I can't get six father pretty stupid
move King doesn't really do anything in
there but ok after it to catch up it's
time wise yes a slightly better game
also can't doesn't do much but ok this
is why King u6 was stupid and you know
when to check sium
ok so if time night is not already doing
more than much
now get you the double poem it's a
little bit like being a pond down there
three against two it I don't think it is
that straightforward c5 if you will
capture I guess time warning though I've
97 stop it
check check okay now I'm two pawns up
but it's very difficult to do anything
here I mean very difficult is a nice way
to put it it's just impossible to it
just convert the pawns gras a third yeah
I cannot do anything with black you can
just stay and in this particular case
lose on time check yeah you can play a
blu your moves now cannot do much check
yeah when you lose on time this is the
thing I mean you just back if I do
commentary on this I'm going to get so
much negative negative comments again I
mean you just shuffle around for without
any purpose complete lack Rosanna really
not trying to play well at least not at
all yeah okay just great stuff you sit
there with two pawns down and and now
you can shuffle around forever in this
idiotic position yeah you cannot do
anything else black it's the problem you
just stay there with your two pawns and
he has a million rules you can never
expel the King from you form and then
you just lose on time because this is
what the time control is you have no way
forward i got i played c65 but he just
stays of course and yeah i tried this is
for stuff just to make something
abstract but because i was just losing
one time anyway and here you for
actually wins but they have no time I
mean something like that maybe it wins
the engine says it means but that
doesn't really mean that much here check
hey okay in this particular case it
probably has to maybe not even that well
the question is just can I in that in
that time man do something him yeah okay
the problem also he was of course the
opening when you just played instant
moves the whole time and I don't know
that long at all I intend to check it
but night air force what the engine
suggests here I don't know I just don't
know the opening I was really concerned
that something could happen yeah and
okay i mean i'm spending ages and he
play
place in symbols the position is just
pretty equal I think he's a little bit
better after I walked through 6 which
doesn't make much sense but I mean me
Nina didn't even try something yeah
Bishop t4 and yeah if I've just
bluntness this stuff but ok why this so
solid that is not losing this probably i
hearby five is strong but i already
wasn't a bit of a panic mode down yeah
now he has to take on b5 and that's
pretty much the end of it well chat but
after i went with this relatively
passive play here check i'm in this some
indus time trap let's say yeah where he
will win on time because he can play
million moves and I can't and he always
says some kind of stupid for move to
delay a 1550 move ruler even if I should
play a quick moves dad sister negative
side about those ancient dumb controls
and you can spend time and and then at
the end you have to a pissed because
I've been having game like that anyway
thanks for watching